hi I'm Terry Crews and I'm doing the
wired auto-complete interview I'm scared
it's Terry Crews in the Hall of Fame yes
I am in Flint Michigan I am in the
African American Sports Hall of Fame is
Terry Crews Spanish no hablo espanol
no it's Terry Crews bigger than the rock
Wow
no no I'm not he's taller than me he's
got more money than me even my wife has
a crush on him that's crazy
I call him a big bro so that's okay it's
Terry Crews in blackish no Terry Crews
is black but he's not in blackish thank
you what is Terry Crews let's see what
does Terry Crews eat Terry Crews loves
desserts that's for real what is Terry
Crews doing now Terry Crews is doing
this interview right here for Wired
what does Terry Crews do I do a lot of
things I am an artist I'm on Brooklyn
nine-nine I'm in Deadpool - I have
another movie called sorry to bother you
I act I host sometimes I sing but it's
usually funny
what is cherry Cruz's workout my workout
is with weights lots of weights as heavy
and as big as I can do it because I like
muscles what happened to Terry Cruz's
ways you know when I did ways and I was
a voice on ways it was a promotion for
Brooklyn nine-nine and it went viral
like crazy the Terry Crews ways I was
like turn left turn right you have
reached your destination and you know
people loved it the kids loved it they
were like where did Teague this wadies
go Nath why Terry Crews why is Terry
Crews famous I don't know
I don't know I don't have any idea maybe
this makes you famous you know being
able to pop your pecs a little bit
why did Terry Crews retire Terry Crews
never retired why is Terry Crews not
voicing doom fish I know you know what
I'm a big gamer and it just didn't work
out I'm sorry but I am in my own video
game called crackdown 3 where I am a
playable character
why did Terry Crews replace mr. T
there's this movie called Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs I asked him if it
was okay and I was the voice of his
character and Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs 2 he had no problem with it
and neither did I it was fun Terry Crews
Terry Tate know that is a big confusion
God lester spate is a good friend of
mine he did those rebound ads where he
played a character named Terry Tate
where he would tackle people in offices
and do all this stuff but the confusion
was my name is Terry so people began to
confuse us as you know oh man you're
Terry Tator I know I'm not as so many
people I love those commercials you were
Terry Tate I might know what that's my
friend Lester sorry about that
I was never Terry Tate it's Terry Crews
related to Eddie Murphy well we're both
black but we're not related
he put me in Norbit he actually wrote
the role in the movie Norbit for me so I
feel like yes we are related he's Uncle
Eddie Murphy to me it's Terry Crews
vegan hell no it's Terry Crews married
yes I am married to a beautiful woman
named Rebecca we have five beautiful
kids we even have an 8 year old
grandbaby let me tell you we're building
a dynasty y'all it's two crews and
artists yes I am an artist that's the
first thing I've ever knew how to do
since I was five years old and I'm still
doing it and when I'm sketching and
drawing and painting and doing that
thing and I will do that until I'm long
gone
wait till the Terry Crews Art Show you
won't believe it
who Terry Crews oh man who is Terry
Crews related to well probably not many
people you would know but I'm related to
my family who does Terry Crews look like
you know I was funny because you know I
think I just look like me
I've had people come bail you know you
look like to recruit I mean yeah I know
who did Terry Crews play NFL football
for man I joined the NFL in 1991
for the LA Rams then I went to the
Packers as Chargers the Redskins and the
Eagles I was not very good six teams in
seven years I was all over the place
but it was good it got me the body that
I wanted who did Terry Crews playing
bridesmaids I played a fitness
instructor who had one of these fitness
camps in the park and I saw Maya Rudolph
and Kristen Wiig basically copying my
workout for free over by three and I got
angry and I called him out on it
I love cameos they do really good for
you did you know everybody's like oh my
god you killed it I'm like thanks and it
was only one day hey Internet this is
Terry Crews I hope I answered all your
questions that clear some things up for
you the mysteries have now been solved
this is the wired autoimmunity
autocorrect and interview thing